hi there steve kaufman
today i'm kind of recovering from a cold
that i had over the weekend
but i want to talk about the wonderful
world of online language learning
you see behind me some of the books that
i have bought in the past many of them
are language learning books
it's a small fraction of all the
language books that i have bought you'll
see also cds
um
i have used so many cds for my
learning of russian german and other
languages
nowadays most of the
content that i need
i can find online
and i can find it more easily
i can download it i can get access to it
right away
i can integrate it with
link which is where i like to learn
languages
which enables me then to use a lot of
language learning
functionality
so the uh limits that we had before like
if i go back i mean i can think back to
50 years ago when i learned chinese
and we had these big open reel
uh tape recorders and now i carry on my
little iphone which i'm now using to
film this video
this vast library of content most of
which i was able to find online
and i am disappointed that more
language learning uh book publishers
don't take better advantage of this for
example
asimil in my arabic learning i have been
mixing asimil
with our mini
stories for me to read the assimil book
and i and i will by the way do a review
of asimil for arabic but i won't do it
today but it's difficult for me to read
arabic you know in a text on paper
because i it's still difficult for me to
anticipate how these words are
pronounced i have only a rough idea of
how they're pronounced whereas if i can
read where i have access to
text-to-speech
i can look it up in the dictionary i can
save a phrase and hear the text to
speech i can review these later on
there's so many more functions available
if i learn this material on link let's
say
so what i had to do for sml i had to pay
someone whom i found again online at the
outsourcing website
to transcribe these so that i could
import them into link of course i can
only use them for my own purpose i can't
share this in our library because of
copyright reasons however i did approach
assimil and asked them i say you know
isn't there some way we could even sell
your units across our website
uh but no they're not interested in that
um
they should sell the e-text i would
gladly even after having paid for the
book
and the uh the cds
i would gladly have paid for a
transcript of the arabic text
for download but it's not available and
i think so many of these language books
which are very well done
uh
you know very good audio at least in the
case of asimil the audio is excellent
and there's no other language there it's
just arabic
it should be possible to access this
material online i think the textbook
publishers are losing out in that regard
but the online world not only enables
you to access content of interest to you
and a level that's at your level
there's also all of the grammar
resources that are available online not
to mention online dictionaries of which
there are tons and many of them again we
connect with at link
and it's interesting content is so
important to language learning
and
i had an exchange on twitter by the way
where um a teacher at a
english language teaching
conference made a presentation about
how to be a feminist language teacher
and i commented that i didn't think that
this was such a good idea that language
teachers should teach language and
shouldn't teach values however wonderful
these values may be uh and
so there was a bit of a back and forth
about that
and uh one person one language teacher
commented that uh no and and so then i
said they should the teacher should just
allow learners to learn from whatever
they're interested in
and the return comment on that was well
you know in this was in england the
curriculum is such that people have to
study certain items
and i think that's another problem i
think the online
learning world language learning world
makes it possible for
a far greater variety of material to be
used as learning material now you don't
want to make it unlimited if you're in a
school you're limited to a certain range
but it's easy enough
the kids don't have to buy a whole bunch
of textbooks it's easy enough
to
enable them to go and search out things
of interest
and learn from that and use all the
tools that are available online and this
gets back again to the whole issue of
the role of teachers uh changing
while on the subject of online uh
learning uh there was another and again
interaction with people on twitter and
facebook is another
aspect of the sort of online world of uh
of language learning that we're now in
and uh someone pointed out that there
was a teacher or there was a program
where they teach arabic literature
starting with the translation so that
people read
the fable or the poem or whatever it
might be in translation first and then
access it in
arabic
in a way that's a good idea because the
more familiar you are with the content
the easier it is to you know process the
new language
i'm not sure i want to do that myself
because part of the fun of reading
literature is
discovering that piece of work i
wouldn't want to read all of
you know a
ukrainian book on history in english and
then go and read it in ukrainian i would
rather
face that content in ukrainian once i'm
at a level where i can do so
uh on the other hand
a lot of
uh material that is in translation in
fact is quite easy harry potter has been
translated into many languages and for
uh say
many people that's easier
language learning material because
typically translations
are not as
obtuse or as
as
as difficult
to use so but again
with the internet we have a wide variety
of choice and we can learn from what
interests us so just to summarize then
the uh the online experience has
liberated the language learner liberated
the language learner from the classroom
from
imposition of content by the teacher
from the need to buy or borrow books and
cds
you know the world is available at our
fingertips
and we can connect with tutors
uh we can connect with
grammar explanations with content and i
think i've only scratched the surface
so
i encourage people to take advantage of
that
i think historically one of the problems
facing the independent learner the
person who goes once or twice a week to
spanish class and doesn't make much
progress was that sense of being
alone
except when you're in the classroom with
your fellow students and nowadays we can
connect with people all over the world
we can connect with interesting content
all over the world
and
it's great for language learning
so there you go thanks for listening bye
for now
[Music]
you